So I'm going to talk about the updated rRNA
databases.
You can use these for identification and phylogenetic
analysis of fungi, bacteria and archea, and
as I said a minute ago Barbara Robbertse is
here and I'm Peter Cooper I'm doing this presentation
even though I'm not a subject matter expert
on this.
So this is the outline were talking today.
Talking a little bit about what target loci
are and then the background on structure of
Ribosomal RNA genes.
The scope and content of the NCBI RefSeq Ribosomal
RNA projects, which include the 16S bacterial
and archaeal, the fungal ITS, which is the
largest one but we also have large subunit
and a small subunit database.
We will talk about retrieving the data and
we will do some live demonstrations.
So we talk about things at NCBI called targeted
loci.
These are marker genes, barcodes, or measuring
tape.
Used for phylogenetic analysis or taxon identification.
This is molecular identification as opposed
to the traditional morphological means like
a colony on a plate.
Examples of these kinds of sequences are Cytochrome
oxidase Park consequences.
Various protein coding genes.
And the mitochondrial D loop, and ones going
to talk about today which are the structural
RNA gene.
For prokaryotes there are the 16S, 23S and
5S.
For eukaryotes there is an 18S, 5.8S and a
28 or 25S depending on the group of organisms,
and a special kind of sequence that's more
variable, it is between the 5.8S and those
other two subunits called the internal transcribed
spacer regions.
ITS1 and ITS2 and also a 5S rRNA gene.
We make sequences for these and we call them
reference targeted loci.
We've got records available from RefSeq.
And the point I want to make today is that
there are BLAST databases we have made for
you to use.
These rRNA genes are from microbes in the
traditional sense of that word in the old-fashioned
sense which include the Prokaryotes, Archaeal
and bacteria.
As well as fungi . The good thing about these
sequences that we produce is that they are
associated for the most part with taxonomic
type material which is material or a specimen
or culture that a new species description
is based on.
This ensures that the correct name is tied
with the sequence.
That's been a big problem with sequences going
into GenBank where the identity might be incorrect.
What are these are useful.
Confirming organism by identification.
If you've got an unknown they are good for
assigning a preliminary ID or placement in
a taxonomic group.
You're not necessarily going to be to identify
the species and will talk more about that.
You can use these to construct polygenic trees.
Or to put them in your trees to get anchor
points.
Let's talk a little bit about the structure
of the rRNA genes in Prokaryotes and eukaryotes.
Here's an example using our sequence viewer.
We'll look at the ribosomal cassette.
There are multiple of these in bacteria.
This is E. coli with seven copies and a 16
S gene shown on the left hand side and that's
the one with got a corresponding record were
talking about today.
This is the RefSeq RNA for this 16S, NR_074891.
This is showing the BLAST alignment for that
part of the E. coli genome.
Here's the 23 S and 5S.
These are the main reagents we'll be talking
about today for bacteria.
And these are genes for a fungus.
This is a yeast, Kazachstania africana, you
can see the structure of the RNA cassette
there.
This is the 5 S the 18S and the 25S large
subunit RNA.
This guy right here, the 5.8, there is a space
between 18 and 25, this is the internal transcribed
spacer regions.
There's 2.
One on each side.
These are more variable than the conserved
genes themselves.
And we make a sequence in this spacer RefSeq
that includes that 5.8 but also some of the
flank on either side so it includes that ITS1
and the ITS 2 sequence .
That's a very useful sequence use for identification
and phylogenetic analysis.
So little bit more about these Targeted loci
data sets that we have.
One way to access them is to the BioProject
site.
There is a number of these and I've highlighted
the ones were talking about today.
16 S for bacteria and archaea, the fungi,
internal transcribed spacer region the ITS,
28 S and 18 S. Those are the BioProject IDs.
These are all a part of these targeted Loci
projects that we have it NCBI.
What's good about these BioProject identifiers
is they are useful for retrieving these sets
of sequences from our Entrez system and I'll
show you that in a bit.
Looking at what kind of organisms and what
kinds of taxonomic distribution we have for
the organisms in the group for 16 S, this
is a breakdown of what groups are represented
and what I have done here is used a name that
is sort of a handle for group of bacteria.
These are the so-called BLAST names we have
in our taxonomy database.
So these are groups that most people recognize.
The highest most represented group are the
high GC positive bacteria and there are a
number of other organisms represented here.
We've got a broad spectrum of things and we
can talk later on.
This is a tiny bit of the microbial diversity
that's out there.
There's 21,333 of these records, 20,000 of
them for bacteria and 979 for Archaeal and
it's about 16,000 species at this point.
The fungal database is smaller there's 11,751
records and 11,665 species represented.
This is a breakdown of the ITS fungal here,
also the 28S and 18S.
They are slightly smaller databases.
And these are BLAST names, not necessarily
names that fungal taxonomists would like to
use.
Barbara did not like them very much but they
are good handles for groups of fungi.
This is a better breakdown of the taxonomic
coverage basically by showing the number of
records at the various levels, phylum, class,
order, genus and species for the small subunit
the ITS and the large subunit.
Barbara made the slide it's very nice and
shows you the number in the various groups
so for Ascomycota there's a large group with
8,492 records and so on down to the species
level.
And in terms of phylogenetic analysis a lot
of times people want to use combinations of
genes.
The table at the bottom of the slide shows
you what we have for a particular taxon.
So the last line is the one that we have everything
for.
The small subunit, ITS and the large subunit.
So that's 1400 2 taxa for that and she shows
you those taxa that are the most represented.
And there is coverage breakdown by phylum,
class, order family and genus.
These are useful if you want to use both or
as many of the genes in a phylogenetic tree.
You can get those from the RefSeq FTP site.
If you're looking at one of these records.
This is the flat file of one of these records
to show you the kind of information that is
on here.
You can see these in our Entrez system.
First of all, the definition line is controlled
by the RefSeq curators.
The organism information will be updated with
the correct organism and what happens is a
lot of times with the GenBank record is the
definition line organism will be out of date
even though taxonomy is updated in the organism
field.
The important thing about the def line when
we talk about the blast databases is that
this is the thing that shows up in the blast
description.
A lot of people are looking at the species
name so it's useful for these RefSeq records
to ensure that the species name is the best
when we can come up with.
Here's a link to the RefSeq BioProject.
Here's a link to the original Genbank or record
that was used to make this record.
What's nice here is that you can go back to
BioCollections and look at the culture collection
and you can link to the outside culture collection
directly, e.g., ATCC, and see about how you
would order this culture to verify it yourself.
This is a 16S record this is for Lactobacillus
delbrueckii, and there's the RefSeq accession
number here, NR_188558.
Here's the corresponding record for one of
the ITS sequences for fungus, Trichophyton
rubrum.
You have the curated def line the BioProject
link and the link to the outside culture collection,
CBS, where you can order this particular culture
if you wanted to verify and work on it yourself.
So let's talk about how you can get access
to these data.
You can get them directly from our Entrez
Nucleotide system.
It's easy to download these because they are
not huge sets of sequences.
You can use these queries, 33175[bioproject],
the BioProject number followed by the square-bracketed
field, in the Nucleotide system to get the
sets, then use the send to menu to download
these.
If you want the set in handy file you can
go to our RefSeq FTP site,
https://ftp.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/refseq/TargetedLoci,
the URL is given here there is a targetedloci
directory that has access to the bacteria,
archaea
and the fungal sequences.
And the other thing I want to mention and
one of the things we want to promote is that
you can get these as blast databases.
They are also available on the web so that's
what we're using for our examples.
They are on the blast FTP site in the blast
db directory, https://ftp.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/blast/db.
You can get the ones were talking about today,
the 16S, 18S, 28S and the ITS.
These are the RefSeq databases.
I will point out that there are sequences
there that we have gleaned from GenBank for
these particular regions for other organizations.
I'm not going to talk about those databases
today but you're welcome to check them out.
One cool thing bout the blast databases now
is we've got these version 5 databases.
The taxonomy information it's baked in to
them and you can use switches in the blastdbcmd
program to dump out various things, what organisms
are in there, what the accession numbers are
and all these type of things.
That's very handy.
The other thing that's nice about getting
a blast databases even if you don't run a
blast against them directly you can use them
as a way of dumping out sequences in various
formats.
This is a nice way to get the FASTA to use
in other applications.
And one thing I should point out is those
databases are non-redundant.
So there might be cases where the sequence
for different species is the same they will
be collapsed into a single FASTA but you'll
still be able to see the two titles in the
blast database.
If you really want to have every FASTA sequence
you want to use the RefSeq download if you
want all the records instead of the non-redundant
set that is part of blast.
So let me point out a few things that are
important to realize when using these types
of targeted loci, an important one I alluded
to earlier is that this is limited coverage
of the taxonomic representatio.
So if you just do a quick count of the species
level nodes at NCBI these are often things
that don't have formal names just things that
are at the end of the taxonomy classification.
There's 450,000 bacteria and 150,000 fungi.
For bacteria we've got only 16,000 species
in the 16S database and for fungi there's
only 12,000 species in the ITS database.
Who knows how many species of microbes there
are on the planet.
I've seen estimates upwards of 10 to the 30th
species so this is just the tip of the iceberg
in terms of the diversity.
If you got an unknown sequence, there may
not be the corresponding species in these
databases.
And just using 16S and ITS alone, there might
be a lot more species out there.
There's going to be some species that are
not separable based on the ITS or 16S alone
you need to use a multi-gene analysis to get
accurate identification and to get phylogenetic
trees.
The technique were talking about today that
searches these is blast and if hyou go to
the blast page now you have a separate radio
button that you can click and you have access
to these databases from a pulldown list.
You can restrict to only those from type material.
And most are from type material.
That's all very good.
Keep in mind and we'll see examples of this
in a few minutes that there's some limitations
that BLAST has.
It sorts by e-value and alignment score and
not by the percednt identity.
This causes some things to happen that might
be confusing at first.
Your longer sequence that is a worse match
might appear higher in the results so take
a look at both query coverage and the percentage
identity to help identify things.
Also BLAST does not use position specific
information in the alignment.
So every position gets equal weight and in
reality some are more informative than others.
Look at how the match fits in to a tree with
the results to get a better idea of the placement.
You might need to build trees using real multiple
sequence alignments and tree building with
multiple genes to get an accurate view of
things.
Let's do some live examples.
I'm going to switch over to a web browser.
This is where it would be useful if you want
to follow along to try to get the text document
that is on the FTP site.
So if you go to the site you can see this
is a run-through that we're going to do for
the demo.
The first is just do a simple blast search
and a search to find a particular targeted
locus sequence.
Let's use one of those queries that we talk
about searching for the BioProject.
I'm going to add an organism search to it.
This is an archea that we have a 16S sequence
for.
I'm going to the Nucleotide database
and Notice that we've have two different 16S
sequences.
That's because there's divergence from each
other.
This is an unusual situation this is an organism
with two central replicons.
You can find this cassette in the genomes.
Let's do that as an example to show you how
these things line up and take a look at an
rRNA operon.
I'm going to click Run BLAST.
What this is going to do is to put these two
sequences into the blast form.
Notice that we could search against the rRNA
databases but were not going to do that right
now.
Going to search against the genomes.
There's a special set of genomes, representative
genomes, at NCIB.
This is one that's in there.
I'll type in the species name to limit our
search.
We want Haloarcula marismortui, so let's go
ahead and run that.
If you want to retrieve the results and you
didn't run the search yourself.
You can do that pretty easily from the URL
that I've given you here.
I've saved these blast results.
If you just copy and paste the URL into the
web browser, you should be able to retrieve
them.
I've got mine back here.
Notice we've got a hit on these two different
chromosomes here's a set of results for the
first sequence it matches this perfectly.
The first sequence matches the chromosomes
less perfectly, 92.4 percent identity.
You can see if you switch over to the other
sequence here.
That we now swap them.
And if we want to take a look at this you
can jump down to the alignment.
Let's take a look at the graphics view
It's a nice way of looking at the results
here.
There are the two sequences we searched with.
If we zoom out a little bit you can see on
the opposite strand there's 16 S, 20 3S and
5 S and here's our perfect match to this portion
of the chromosome.
This is a case where we hit two different
16S sequences because of the divergent 16S
regions on these.
Let's do another exercise with 16S.
What I have here if you want to follow along
there are three different
sequences from some Bacillus species that
don't have species identification on them.
So we can try to find the best species match
for these against the 16S database.
I'm going to copy those.
I can go back here to edit my search to get
to the blast page and I can Reset page to
start over again.
This is our first look at the rRNA/ITS databases.
I'll select the radio button for that and
select the top one that's the one we want
the 16S.
Won't change any other parameters.
I can check the box for sequences from type
material just to make sure I'm looking at
the type strains here and run blast.
There are three sets of results for the three
different ones that we searched with and let's
take a look at this.
We've got some potential matches here.
One thing I want you to notice is, and this
is the point that I made earlier, there's
differences in the length of these sequences
that we have made.
So what happens is, the best match which is
Bacillus drentensis, is lower down so what
I want to do a lot of times as to make sure
I'm getting the best identity is to sort by
percent identity.
Then I can see that my best match is Bacillus
drentensis, and another one here for a different
strain of Bacillus drentensis.
The other thing you can do to sort of verify
things by look at the distance tree of results.
We'll do that more than once today.
Just to see how it fits in the tree.
You can expand this node here and zoom into
see what's going on with that.
So here it is.
Fitting between those two Bacillus drentensis
sequences.
So now do I know that this is the species?
I don't know for sure.
It's close to that particular species.
I won't go to the other ones it's pretty much
the same exercise.
And the reason this is happening is because
this NR_ sequence here is shorter than the
other ones and that's where we get a lower
query coverage even though the percent identity
is higher.
So that is why matches might be dropped down
a little bit in your blast results.
So moving on it.
Let's move over to a fungal clone.
I'm going to retrieve it so you can see what
this is.
I'm going to retrieve this from the Nucleotide
database.
This is from a PopSet at NCBI where people
have submitted a whole bunch of sequences.
This is an uncultured soil fungus.
There is a clone and we don't really know
what it is.
They have identified that it contains a part
of the 18S and internal transcribed spacer
region 1 and so on and so forth.
So we can run a search with this.
By running a blast and picking one of our
rRNA/ITS databases but this time let's pick
the ITS.
This is a fungal sequence and we'll do a blast
search with that.
Again we have to make sure we are looking
at the best matches here so sort by percent
identity.
And if I do that my best match is Penicillium
subrubescens here.
Is this the species that were sure it is?
We cannot be sure but this is the best match
and we can take a look at the tree and see
if that confirms what were thinking about.
It still comes out to be the closest thing
in this group of organsisms.
Those that I showed you work pretty well.
The last thing I want to do is fairly complicated
one involving several steps.
I want to point out to you on the last one
that basically there's some things you'll
need to think about.
The database and the length of the query sequence
matter in terms of the identification that
you might get.
So I'm going to go back to the handout.
This is a fungal sequence that Barbara provided
to me.
We can start out by doing a search against
a different database which is the default
nucleotide database.
I'll change my database to Standard nucleotide
databases here.
I'll keep my limit to Sequences from type
material on.
Go ahead and run that.
For the moment let's just look at her best
matches.
We have these Cortinarius species, ceskae
looks like it is the best match.
Let's take a look at that match I want to
point something out to you.
If we take a look at the graphics link will
give us some information as to what it looks
like.
One thing is, the sequence that we are dealing
with, the query sequence, incorporates more
than just the ITS regions.
So here's 28 S. It has a big chunk of the
28S in it so that's an important thing to
keep in mind.
For example we could think about doing a search
against the 28S database.
Looking at the mismatches you've got mismatches
in the ITS regions but nothing within the
5.8 or the 28S.
This does tell me that the query is longer
than just the ITS region.
Let's go back and run this against the ITS
type strain database and see what that comes
out like.
Change to ITS here on the blast form.
We'll run this search.
We now have a different species at the top,
phoeniceus.
Notice that you can see the coverage is 71%
as pointed out before, the query sequence
is longer than the sequence that we are matching.
And ceskae which was number one before is
now number 3.
Let's do the thing we did before and go to
the Distance Tree and see what comes up when
that happens.
You can expand that and zoom to look at it.
So now when we look at the distance tree results
the closest species is this one, cinnamomeus
and if you look up here you can find the other
ones in the tree, in different parts of the
tree the ones we had before.
We now have a different closest match so let's
do one more thing which is to sort by percent
identity.
Now we have croceus as our best match.
That's the one that gives us the best percent
identity.
We've identified 4 different closest matches
and which one is it?
That's a good question.
In order to figure that out you might find
that you can't figure it out.
There is a slide that Barbara showed me of
a phylogenetic analysis.
I'm going to switch back to the slides to
show you the results of that.
These are the species that we've looked at,
croceus, cinnamomeus, and phoeniceus.
They are closely related to each other.
It shows you where these things are and all
we can say is that it belongs to this species
group.
We can't give a clear species identification.
So that's just a cautionary tale of the kind
of things you're going to run into using blast
as a tool and the fact that we have a limited
taxonomic coverage for these organisms.
We have about 10 minutes for questions.
This slide shows you where you can get some
more information.
These are our resources for learning about
things.
For questions you can write to our helpdesk,
info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov.
And Rana are there any questions we can answer?
[Rana Morris] Sure there are a lot of questions.
The first thing would like to talk about initially
are the targeted loci databases.
There's a number of questions about what types
of sequences are actually located in that
particular database.
One question was about what kind of sequences
are there.
One of the people on the webinar mentioned
about how there's many databases out there
with different levels of quality of sequences
and what exactly goes into that targeted loci
database and what is the level of curation.
Is it possible to expand these databases and
maybe fragment them into those that have good
curation and those that have uncultured sequences
of from metagenomic profiling.
What goes into these targeted loci databases?
[Peter Cooper] I think Barbara can answer
that question best.
[Barbara Robbertse] For the RefSeq ITS database,
first we do a lot of sequence quality control
looking at non-ATG characters so there are
not too many of those.
We allow only 0.5% characters to be in our
dataset per sequence.
We look at the assembly.
Making sure correctly assembled.
We use the ITSx program to make sure everything
is present and we also use this to check how
complete our sequences are.
Some of our sequences will have a flank on
the small subunit side and the large subunit
side but it will never be longer than 100
bases.
So about 50% of the data set is actually complete
ITS1 to ITS2.
Where they are partial we have generated a
statistic where we look for genus and what's
the expected length for ITS1 and for ITS2
and if we are covering 80% of either we allow
it to go in.
Otherwise if we are too strict in housing
fully complete ITS one and two sequences then
we will have too few copies of the fungal
kingdom.
Let's see what else.
We make sure there's no bookkeeping errors.
We check the sequence name association, and
we check that the sequences do not sit in
weird places in the phylogenetic tree that
doesn't make sense in terms of its classification
in the NCBI taxonomy.
[Peter] And I would say, Barbara you talked
about the fungal sequences, but the bacterial
sequences are curated in a similar way.
The second part of the question was about
making available the uncultured sequences.
I don't know that we have any plans to do
that.
There's certainly places you can get access
to those sequences.
[Barbara] Yes.
We don't have any plans to do that.
People can go to the UNITE database.
They do sequence quality control and sequence
clustering and try to add species names.
[Peter] Thanks.
Rana we are close to time but maybe you can
pick out one more question that would be a
popular one.
[Rana] There are a number that are popular
but let's go into the sequences.
Looking for guidance on fungal identification
and also bacterial as well.
Is the ITS fungal identification specific
enough?
Are there other genes that might be good to
include or would enhance the ability to identify
fungal sequences to the species level and
is it possible to have more than just one
ITS and maybe another gene in order to do
the identification and the tree generation.
[Barbara] Yes, so there are some secondary
barcodes that are important particularly for
trichoderma and fusarium.
One of those protein coding barcodes is called
elongation factor one and that can be used.
In terms of other tools.
Tree placement tools is probably the best
tool to use.
There is a group called T-BAS.
They maintain a reference tree you can use
your ITS or elongation factor sequences and
search against the tree and it will have placement
of your sequence it will be shown highlighted
in the tree.
So your sequence is like fusarium, like trichoderma
whatever.
I think they only do this for the filamentous
fungi.
Other tools might be clustering tools but
I would stay away from it an use a tree placement
tool.
Other barcoding sequences you can use would
be RPB1 and RBP2 but I think the elongation
factor one is probably the best protein coding
gene to use after ITS.
It depends on the plate or the genus you're
working with.
I suggest doing some homework and if you're
working on a specific genus go and see what
the literature says about genes other than
ITS which is the typical gene to use.
[Peter] We are essentially out of time so
I'm going to end the webinar.
And Thanks Rana and Barbara.
Thanks everybody.